this is Jocko podcast number 229 with
echo Charles and me Jocko Willing good
evening echo good evening
leadership means firmness not harshness
or bullying understanding not weakness
justice not irresponsible freedom humane
this
not intolerance generosity not
selfishness pride not egotism so a
little quote for you to kick things off
this is coming but I ran across it the
other day and as I ran across it I saw
some of a little bit of that economy a
leadership in there and it just caught
my attention and it's a quote from
General Omar Bradley a general with a
good amount of name recognition but a
general who kind of flew under the radar
sometimes because he was competing with
some some big names you know he's
competing with General Patton he's
competing with General Eisenhower he's
competing with general Montgomery so he
kind of flew under the radar sometimes
even though he does have the Bradley
Fighting Vehicle named after him which
is a an awesome machine but he
absolutely was a well regarded general
in his own right born in 1893 in
Randolph County Missouri worked as a
boilermaker figured out he could get a
free education by going to West Point so
he went to West Point graduated in 1915
same year as Eisenhower by the way he
was a really good athlete baseball star
could have played pro ball but chose to
be in the army chose to go and do his
commitment to the army so 1915 you're
probably thinking World War one WWI well
he actually didn't go to World War one
he didn't go and fight in World War one
there were mining disputes in the unions
in the in the mines up in Montana and
they had to activate some army units to
send him up there to guard the mines and
that's what he did he did that for a
little while and then he did go to unit
that was getting ready to deploy to
World War one the Spanish flu came which
everyone seems to know about the Spanish
flu now and they would then there was
the Armistice and he didn't deploy so he
didn't get any combat action in World
War one thought that that might hurt his
career but he stayed in anyways ended up
teaching tactics at the infantry school
fast forward through the peace years
made general in 1942
assigned the 82nd division then the 28th
National Guard division eventually
worked under General Patton as the
deputy in charge of 2nd corps and then
took it over himself led the campaigns
in Tunisia and Sicily Ike Eisenhower
selected Bradley to command the 1st army
during Operation Overlord d-day command
he commanded the most troops of any
general US General in history when he
took command of the 12th Army Group 1.3
million troops little decentralized
command let her come into play right
there
continue with all those troops to push
through Europe till the fall of Germany
we covered Ernie Pyle on this podcast
podcast number 39 his book brave men it
was the heavies one of my favorite lines
Ernie Pyle nicknamed him the GI general
because he was kind of a lay back down
to earth guy didn't make a spectacle of
himself after the war he ran the VA for
a while the Veterans Administration
first-ever chairman of the Joint Chiefs
of Staff during the Korean War retired
in 1953 after 38 years of service I
found a the Internet is amazing yes sir
I found an evaluation you know we talked
about the evaluations
evaluation the Marine Corps evaluation
the Navy evaluation
I found an evaluation of Bradley written
by General Patton it's pretty cool
because it shows it shows what type of a
person Patton was just in the way he
wrote this thing so it says subject
efficiency report through commanding
general NATO USA APO 534 to adjutant
general War Department Washington DC
name and grade of general officer
reported on Omar F Bradley lieutenant
general period covered 1 July 1943 to 8
September 1943 two months and eight days
duties performed commanding general to
Corps 1 July 1943 to 8 September 19
something unclear manner of performance
superior physical activity superior
physical endurance superior knowledge of
his profession superior for what command
or duty would you specifically recommend
him and army and then what opportunities
have you had for observing him during
period covered intimate daily contact
does he render a willing and generous
support to plans of superiors regardless
of personal views in the matter yes
which is a very interesting topic to
cover I mean you think about what
they've got in their physical duty not
knowledge of his profession what job
would you recommend and then does he
give generous supports to plant plans of
superiors regardless of his personal
views in the matter so this guy's gonna
back you up the answer there is yes and
10 of all general officers of his grade
personally known to you what number
would you give him on this list and how
many comprise your list and Patton's
answer is number one I know all of them
[Laughter]
further remarks deemed necessary none
signed GS Patton jr. Lieutenant General
US Army commanding so that's a pretty
awesome review the interesting thing is
if you know anything about the history
of Bradley and Patton there's some
interesting dynamics there they first of
all they had very different
personalities that was you know flashy
and the ego ego driven in a lot of ways
and and Bradley was not and there's some
quotes I pulled from Patton's Journal
journals about Bradley so it's
interesting that he could have these
right in that glowing like evaluation
about him to try and get him promoted
but at the same time here's some things
he said about him Bradley is too
conservative he wants to wait until we
can all jump into the fight together by
which time half our men will be will
have the flu or trench foot I wish he
had a little more daring another one
Bradley is a good officer but he utterly
lacks it too bad the it factor echo
Charles mmm next one Bradley is a man of
great mediocrity on the other hand he
has many attributes which are considered
desirable in a general he wears glasses
which I have no idea I have no idea why
that's cool to be a general he wears
glasses he has a strong jaw he talks
profoundly and says little and he is a
shooting companion of our present chief
of staff general Marshall also he is a
loyal man I consider him to be among our
better generals another quote we had a
lot quite a long talk and I told Bradley
a lot of my best ideas to tell general
Marshall I suppose I should have kept
them to myself but I am not built that
way
the sooner they are put into effect the
better it will be for Army so there here
we see a little a little plant in the
seed room you know leading up the chain
of command right there and then he says
it was really a great plan holy my own
and I made
Bradley believed that he thought of it
but that's exactly what I talked about
go plant the seed let him think it's
wrong idea but because it's patenting
because he's got a little bit that ego
that kicks in he he also wrote this I do
not wish any more of my ideas to be used
without credit to me which is what
happens when I give them orally to
Bradley
how's that for short-sighted that's sad
to read a little bit Saturday yes
another one where ego gets the best of
Patton he says Courtney Hodges and Omar
Bradley both received a Distinguished
Service Medal for their unsuccessful
defense of the Bulge I did not receive
one for successfully defending it so
clearly these guys had a you know an
interesting relationship general Bradley
also wrote a book and it's from what I
gather his aide-de-camp did most of the
writing which I'm not saying that's a
horrible thing because writing is a is a
mechanical thing that you have to do and
if you can get someone to catch your
ideas and do it well then it's fine but
the book was released in 1951 it's
called a soldier's story
it's a 600 page book details his
experiences in the army obviously
especially in World War two and I'm sure
we're gonna cover that book at some
point we're not doing it today but you
know when I after I read that quote
about him and you know just talking
about leadership and kind of the
dichotomies that are there I remember
this short piece that I haven't I got a
bunch of these little short things at a
certain file folder in my computer and
they're mold to I've been collecting him
for a long time what's the name of the
file it's books and PDFs but I have this
thing books and PDFs that I just
download I saved them into books and
PDFs I got a lot of them we've covered a
bunch of them too on this podcast so I
remembered this one of his and in his
called
leadership
general of the army Omar and Bradley
this articles first published in a
winter 1972 issue of parameters which is
the magazine of the US Army War College
editor's note general to the army omar
and bradley visited Carlisle barracks on
seven to eight October 1971 to meet with
members of the 12th Army Group
Association while he was at Carlisle he
addressed the Army War College faculty
and students on the subject of
leadership his address contained
observations that were gleaned during a
long and significant career a careful
reading of his remarks give us soms
gives us some insight into the qualities
that made general Bradley the great
soldier and human being that he is
general Bradley's thesis is that
leadership is an intangible that
involves a constant interplay between
the leader and the lead when this
interplay is successful we have the
ingredients for great accomplishment so
there you go kicking into it all of you
here this evening are leaders I am
pleased to meet you
what you do may well dignify the past
explain today and secure for all of us
tomorrow perhaps I can touch upon a few
factors that will underscore the value
of good leadership leadership is an
intangible no weapon no impersonal piece
of machinery ever designed can take its
place it's an interesting idea that
leadership is intangible have you ever
heard that expression that somebody
asked for the definition of pornography
and the Supreme Court Justice said I
can't give you a definition but I know
it when I see it something like that
it's a weird thing right because
leadership if you're going to define it
specifically it's kind of the same
answer right look I can't tell you
exactly what it is but I know it when I
see it and you see different people do
it differently yeah and you can see two
different people say or do the same
thing but be like hey this guy's leading
in this case sort of not you know he's
doing something else you know yeah yeah
there's in leadership strategy and
tactic side I give some
talking about pride and the same comp
the same sentence about pride depending
on who is saying it and what context it
is can be negative or positive yeah
for instance that guy's full of pride
right yeah or that guy's full of pride
you know what I mean like that's the
same sentence yeah but it's two
completely different things yeah so
continuing on this is the age of the
computer by the way this is 1971 and if
you know how to program the Machine you
can get quick and accurate answers but
how can you include leadership and
morale which is affected by leadership
into your programming let us never
forget the great importance importance
of this element leadership and while we
use computers for certain answers let us
not try to fight a whole war or even a
single battle without giving proper
consideration to the element of
leadership leadership is the most
important thing on the battlefield your
little calculator over there we're gonna
be covering a podcast shortly about the
creation of Top Gun and same thing
there's some people that would do the
calculations of this this aircraft
versus that aircraft and think well this
aircraft is the superior aircraft it
will win how many times is that wrong
what are they not calculated they're not
calculating the human element how many
times have you watched a UFC fight where
on paper
everyone thought person a was gonna win
and person B wins because the human
element yeah they don't calculate it
yeah so how can we expect to calculate
what's gonna happen in combat without
trying to figure out what implication
leadership has on it continue on another
element to be considered is the man to
be led and with whose morale we are
concerned I have constantly reminded of
this point by a cartoon which hangs over
my desk at home which depicts an
infantryman with his rifle across his
knees
he sits behind a parapet above him is
the list of the newest weapons science
has devised the newest weapons science
has devised and the soldier behind the
parapet is saying but they still haven't
found out the substitute for me so
there's a human beings of course with
this particular group of service
personnel I am considering leadership as
it applies to a military unit however
having been associated with industry for
some time now I find it difficult to
completely separate the principles of
military and industrial leadership they
have much in common
yeah and he retired in 1953 this is 1971
he worked with some companies I know he
was the like the chairman of Belova
Bulova how do you say Bulova watch
company bul OVA you know over Bulova mmm
he was the chairman of that so that's a
big company so he understood the same
thing that we now know to be true and
that's a strong statement did I say it
yes I did
we know to be true I couldn't have told
you this ten years the day I retired
from the from the Navy I couldn't have
told you that military and civilian
leadership are the same I couldn't have
answered that question I didn't know it
mmm I didn't know the answer it was
until I started working with civilian
companies that I said oh these are the
same the same principles employed in
both situations and that's what Omar
Bradley is saying here he says they have
much in common they have more than much
they have a lot in common
mmm I'd go so far as to say they have
everything in common but there's
differences but I'll tell you the
differences between leading an army
platoon leading a Marine Corps platoon
those there's little differences there
are the same differences between leading
a gas station and a construction site
there's so going from one construction
site to another concert there's little
differences mm-hmm and I used to say
that about seal platoons because like
the difference between a seal platoon
and another super tune are the same
differences that you find there's just
going to be different
in those situations the principles don't
change the principles don't change
leading the construction sites that
Prince's principles don't change leading
a manufacturing line the principles
don't change leading a Girl Scout troop
leadership is leadership moving on in
selecting a company in which to invest
our savings we often give primary
consideration to the company with good
leadership in similar manner a military
unit is often judged by its leadership
good leadership is essential to organiz
organized action where any group is
involved now if you were to dig down
into this right here I'm here to tell
you if you're going to invest in a
company the number-one thing you should
look at is what's the leadership like
because if they have a great product
groundbreaking product but they have
horrible leadership it doesn't matter
mm-hmm leadership should be the number
one you component you look at when we
work with big investment groups
sometimes they're wanting us just to
tell them do an assessment make an
assessment what what does this
leadership pod like one of these humans
like are they good leaders do they have
capabilities do they have potential are
they bad like those are the questions
continue on the one who commands be he a
military officer or captain of industry
must project power an energizing power
which coordinates and marshals the best
efforts of his followers by supplying
that certain something for which they
look to him be it guidance support
encouragement example or even new ideas
and imagination projecting power that's
an interesting concept and look I'd love
to tell you well you know that's you
know you didn't need to protect but if
you dig a little bit deeper on that
statement mmm it's fairly accurate
projection of power yeah appear powerful
just just saying hey I got this we can
do this you know what I mean yeah I
guess it's a form of confidence yeah
which he talks about later but I think
that that projection of power and an
energizing power
yes that's what he's talking about which
coordinates and marshals the best
efforts you've seen this before right
let's just look at them a kind of a
generic situation you see a group
they're not really focused they're not
really making anything happened and all
of a sudden the leader steps up takes
control exhibits that power and they and
marshals those people to move in the
same direction that's what leadership is
yeah you're watched American Beauty you
ever watched that movie I have seen it
but I don't really remember pretty good
but there's a part this guy his name was
man I forget his name but he called
himself the king of real estate and it's
kind of a one-off character and he said
to the lady I forget her name something
Burnham anyway sister the lady Oh call
me crazy but it's my philosophy that in
order to be successful one must project
an image of success at all times
interesting this way super cheesy right
if you project an image as successful at
all time when are you projecting you're
vulnerable
vulnerability when are you projecting
your humility yeah right if you're just
walking around by the the the the murk
yeah right and your roll in with the
Rolex
wait what some work Mercedes yes sir
okay I understand rollin with the Merc
and the Rolex the roll ejecting success
yeah but I don't I don't know I I don't
necessarily well never I don't agree
with it well when I heard I was like
probably you just supposed that's what
it was like basically it was because
like he just broke up with his girl and
then the lady was like oh I thought you
guys were doing so well or whatever and
then he was saying that it was alive
essentially yeah it was like basically I
put on an image of success to be
successful in my business I don't know
whatever I got a better idea if we want
to be successful why don't you be humble
mmm why don't you step up and work hard
there's a bunch of other better ways to
be successful than pretending to be
successful
I'm gonna throw that out there right now
I agree continuing on the test of a
leader lies in the reaction and response
of his followers that's straightforward
mm-hmm
the reaction response look if you're a
leader and people don't react correctly
you're failing he should not have to
impose Authority
say it again he should not have to
impose Authority bossiness in itself
never made a leader he must make his
influence felt by example and the
instilling of confidence in his
followers the greatness of a leader is
measured by the achievements of the led
it's the ultimate test of his
effectiveness you know I think he
brushes up against a lot of stuff and
this is like my third time reading
through this today and I keep I keep
seeing little connections right I keep
seeing little where he's brushing up
against really important things and and
kind of talking about him talking about
him he kind of passes through him like
mentions them and some of them are
perfect you know he should not have to
impose Authority right that's that's
that's obvious
it's almost like he's uncomfortable
saying it because he continues on by
saying he must make his influence felt
by the example and instilling confidence
others see the thing that I have a
problem I guess I don't know maybe you
can help me instilling confidence in
other what does that mean right there's
a little bit of a lack of explanation
behind that we know what it means maybe
this is why he says leadership is
intangible cuz look we say hey you want
to instill confidence in your people
great thank you yeah but that's that
goes without saying how do we actually
do it right how do we actually do it how
do you instill confidence in people oh
how much you give them something that
they can handle okay that's a good thing
how about we take our team and we go out
and we accomplish up us
pretty simple straightforward objective
and our confidence goes up a little bit
and then we handle more complicated one
we keep doing that and then we give
suborning leaders thing where are you
seeing I'm saying this idea of just you
know making people confident instilling
confidence in your followers great how
do I do it and by the way that's
leadership strategy and tactics that is
that is why I wrote leadership strategy
and tactics because those questions
right there I realized there was a gap
between hey build a relationship with
your boss
that's great Jocko how do I do it how am
I supposed to do that I was on EF online
the other day and I said I said Jamie
because I was talking through someone I
said I got the name I got my next book
and she was like oh great cuz she's
always mad because I'm doing too much
yes and I said because we were talking
to something about ego oh yeah but give
that person a little ego massage
maneuver around plant the seeds all this
I said my next book is gonna be called
what was it ancient techniques of ego
massage therapy right cuz you could
actually do that you could say hey
here's the person that you're dealing
with here's how you want to massage that
ego here's another person
here's another ancient technique of the
ego massage yeah dang that be actually
really good I know good no I'm not even
kidding because that you know you could
tell someone even now like if they don't
have the guidelines like a for real
comprehensive you know instructional
they think it's so easy to take that
kind stuff too far you know like all
just massages ego you got massage ego do
too much and the guys like probably
skates kissing my ass right now or just
try not massage my ego cuz this present
part of Eagle muscle affective ego
massage them not really yelling like
that you're doing it for the sake of you
for sure
yeah for sure if they know you're doing
it yeah they really work as a snitch
yeah alright cool I'm waiting for that
book - yeah yeah
so I'll get I'll get working on it get
cracking
maybe we'll just be a little it'll just
be a little short little handbook couple
techniques for the troops out there you
know what I'll think of I'll think of
other ancient techniques that need
explanations and I'll put them all in up
let's say there's
four sections we mean ancient techniques
I'm just saying that okay yeah sounds
cool yes sir
yeah I probably could write a little
book on that just by watching you do
certain stuff well you know what you can
do to help me is you go oh I saw you do
this and then I can go into that exactly
what I was doing and now cuz you get to
see that what's interesting for you is
you see maneuvering happening yeah on
multiple different fronts yes and I sit
here and tell you hey this is what's
happening over here with this company
this is what the moves gonna be watch
how it unfolds and you're like okay and
then you watch and you go okay yes yes
alright
continuing on too frequently we use the
words leader and commander synonymously
we should not forget that there are farm
farm or staff officers staff officer
assignments then there are command
billets and a good staff officer can and
should display the same leadership as a
commander while it takes a good staff
officer to initiate an effective plan it
requires a leader to ensure that the
plan is properly executed this is good
stuff that we're about to dive into that
is why you and I have been taught that
the work of collecting information
studying at drawing a plan and making a
decision is ten percent of the job
seeing the plan through is the other
ninety percent a well-trained officer is
one who can serve effectively either as
a staff officer or as a commander so by
a staff officer they mean the guy that's
coming up and helping coming up put
together the plan and going through the
logistics of it all that's the purse
that's the that's the staff officer and
then there's a person that makes it
happen that executes sit that's the
commander it's interesting to think this
goes back to what we were talking about
on the last podcast where I was saying
look you're your commander and you're
your troops right you're both of those
things so you can come up with great
ideas in your little head
beautiful plans amazing plans can you
imagine how many people come up with
plans that are actually freaking awesome
but they never
execute them think about that that is a
that is a graveyard a massive infinite
graveyard of incredibly good plans that
never gotta execute on instead of staff
guy in their head
there's a nut see this is that where the
metaphor continues because you got a
staff guy in your head that's coming up
these little plans right these great
plans hey if I start this work out
hey if I start this business hey if I
can bake produce this thing they come up
with these staff officers coming up with
great plans yeah super good job unless
that commander can get the troops in
your head to execute it has no value
whatsoever and and by the way and we've
talked about this that idea by itself is
zero value yeah zero value you come up
with this great idea
hey Jocko I thought this new right
because everyone thinks of a new half
everyday job like this new it's good
GameChanger
okay cool yeah how many of those things
get executed yeah not many so let me ask
you this is your opinion on this uh so
let's say me and another person right
let's say okay let's say somebody says
hey I have this great idea and tells you
you know and it's an N is a good idea
actually and said this is how I'm gonna
execute you know whatever actually
there's so many different snares but
okay this one okay here's the here's my
plan and in it's a I'm starting to worry
about the execution of this very i watch
this unfold
let's see what's absolutely okay and
then I don't have the capability to
execute this plan at all you know there
are other people's who do but it's just
my ideas man yeah I don't know cap Hill
they're curious cancer you don't know
anything about you know I but let's say
I have that idea I tell you and then
you're like oh good idea and then years
go by and I never execute I never call
somebody up to help execute it you know
I'm just done that was just my idea that
I intended he went into the graveyard
then he said and then you say that is a
good idea I unlike you
have the capability to actually execute
most of this and I know the other guy
who can execute the rest meanwhile me I
don't I don't have any capability and I
don't know anyone I'd have to go
shopping for my and I simply didn't do
it right let's say you say okay and you
execute the plan and be successful in
your new thing mmm right is that like a
violation or well how do you feel about
that because you know that happens a lot
right yeah it definitely happens a lot
and it paints the reality and what's
interesting you ever heard the term idea
guy oh yes like oh that person is a good
idea guy went ahead but it's kind of its
kind of a pejorative right all that guy
well that guy's an idea guy meaning like
hey that guy can't really make anything
happen you can sit around here and spout
off good ideas that's a great so funny
that's great but you don't actually
execute on any of them which is just
what do I think should happen quite
honestly I guess in a perfect world that
person that came up with the idea and
didn't execute it he's paying the price
for not making it happen and the price
is you watch somebody else you know go
and and do well with your idea because
you didn't execute it right so he's
gonna think let's let's say the but
let's say I'm the idea guy in this
particular scenario and near that you're
the guy who can actually make it happen
I mean usually the idea guy is gonna be
kind of salty because he's like hey I I
told you that the whole idea you know
not how to do it but just the idea like
that was my idea you know like on
Seinfeld it was my idea for the cologne
that smells like the beach anyway okay
it's a thing but the but usually that's
why that guy's salty right yeah he's mad
yeah yeah he's mad but the reality is
like Brad not only did you not execute
like I don't even know if you could
really yeah and there's a weird thing
there because if you don't have you said
two things you're not the capability of
executing which is a little bit
different than don't have not having the
will to execute yeah I so this what I
meant was you don't like okay so I I get
this this whole scenario is actually
like a real scenario that happens all
the time back when I used to make
websites like I'd hear it all the time
or and my brother Jay he makes apps so
when you say go to school i defriended
up oh that's a real thing everyone
calling him like I got this idea for
this app right meanwhile they know
nothing about what they're doing at all
yeah like they're like oh this is it
wouldn't it be cool to have an app that
can read people's minds or that's not a
real one but I'm just saying meanwhile
they have no idea about making apps
first off they have no idea about
mind-reading second off and they have no
idea about like anything else you know
they're like but they're like that's a
cool idea let me call the app guy you
know and then so most of the time it's
like even if that were a good idea which
it's not but even if it was I don't need
you for that
to do it you see them saying yeah and
there's a weird thing there because
there's also people that don't have any
good ideas but that are really good at
execution yeah so what I recommend you
do is you form up your team where you
have people that have ideas and people
that can execute those ideas yeah so you
complement each other you work with
someone that can actually make things
happen I couldn't make this podcast I
didn't know how to press record you know
I didn't know how to I didn't know what
piece of equipment we're gonna need
I couldn't execute it I have an idea hey
I think we should do but that's the
exact same thing you're talking about
right now now I could have sat in my
closet by myself corner I'm gonna do a
cool podcast about war and human nature
and it'll be so good I could sat there
for five years with this idea and
someone else would come out maybe I
would have told somebody they would like
help I'm gonna actually hit on that what
did I do
I actually said oh I don't have the
capability to execute this by myself
fine
echo Charles do you know how to make a
podcast yes I can figure it out cool
we're making a podcast that's an example
right
I can't execute it by myself and it
doesn't matter to me I'm not caught up
on the fact that because there's people
that sit on ideas they won't tell you
sign this nd a right I've you know I've
signed so many NBA's for people to tell
me their brilliant ideas and I go steal
it yeah so I won't steal it and it's
like okay cool very few of them I feel
bad people doesn't hiss go to East Side
and India there's some good ideas out
there right now a lot of them
our number one they're real obvious you
know I've had people hit me with a tree
hey man I'm already doing that or hey
that's in the works or whatever cuz just
sorry oh yeah you know but that's a
classic example look I know I can't
execute I'm not gonna sit you know long
i sat on the idea of having a podcast
not very long
yeah I want to have one who can help me
execute this I go Charles boom yeah yeah
man I always I kind of feel it's weird
because when you think about it let's
say I don't know you're a lot more
mature than most of us
dude I'm 48 years old
[Music]
48 I've seen your attitude that your
physical being
you know how I'm saying even at 48 years
old you don't think of like oh this
guy's mature he actually just all 21 you
go he's pretty actually like 17 he's
pretty mature kid right okay I know and
so it but the reason I'm saying is you
understand because this uh this
immaturity versus mercury applies to it
no matter what age so let's say alright
I'm gonna use me I'm not saying I'm like
this I'm not saying not like this but
I'm gonna use me as the example for like
let's say that I'm like hey you know
what be a great idea just in passing to
like I don't know my friend or whatever
let's say he's a surfer surfboard shaper
or something and maybe an engineer too
you know and I'm gonna be a great idea
for a surfboard a little motor on there
so I don't know whatever we'll just say
a motor on there um that that does this
and that yeah you know like just in
passing right that's my cool idea first
off not only do I not know anything
about surfboard making it's like bright
I didn't really even mean like you
should really do that and let's go into
business I didn't mean anything like I
just said it meanwhile it's stuck in the
guy's head where it's like yeah I could
totally do that and no one's doing that
and he does it becomes massively
successful right most of us will have at
least 1% of our little brain saying like
oh man like that's my idea like I
deserve part of it and you know what
that's you if I was the surfboard shaper
mechanical engineer guy
and you gave me that idea and we and I
was successful I would give you reward
yeah I would take care of you
I'd be like cool I think that's I think
that's the right thing to do actually
yeah I think so each other it would
probably be out a different proportion
than you think cuz people with ideas
always think that they they think the
idea is the hard part yeah that's that
everything the idea without an idea
there's nothing right right without an
idea is there's nothing however they're
both equally important but the idea
usually gets less in the investment
world your good idea gets you like 10%
it doesn't get you 90% a lot of people
think your idea is to get them 90% it
doesn't get you 90% it gets you 10% gets
you 15%
yeah and in under certain circumstance
yeah of course out there allottee I
agree with you even 110% you think I
couldn't agree with you hundred ten
percent parently you just I think the
idea part of it is worth less mmm
alright cuz everyone it's like okay okay
here's my idea I'm saying it publicly
straight up here's my idea a pill that
cures cancer just cures it just same
that's a good idea right so you'll kind
of blame that that is like okay so now
one freaking look and not only did a
million trillion people already have
that idea as far as an idea goes like I
have no capability of executing this
maybe I could get like yeah it's kind of
a bad example well it's an agreement
better one no it's an extreme exact so
extreme that it doesn't make it doesn't
make the point you need to think of
something a little bit better well all
these app ideas right we're like kind of
like that it's like you don't even most
of us don't know even how apps work as
far as making them yeah you know what
else is interesting is a lot of times
the first company that has an idea and
invest in it and pushes it a lot of
times they aren't the ones that are
actually successful with that with that
idea from it takes another someone to
take it to the next level the mp3
players Apple didn't invent those there
was other companies that made mp3
players and then Apple came and made it
into the iPod and it was super
successful so there's a lot of times
where the idea phase just to get that
thing launched and then someone else
looks over goes yeah that's a pretty
good idea or jumping on it or jumping in
the game yeah yeah and that kind of goes
back to it in a way so you know back to
what you said where it's like okay if
you got an idea from somebody and then
you actually actually executed the idea
and made successful when they had no
capability or intention by the way and
you became a Sussex Massey's massively
successful when you'd pay them or
whatever reward I don't recall but what
if you didn't know the person what if
you heard the idea on like you're
watching on an old project for runway or
something and you heard like one of the
people say an idea just in passing to
their friend on the show you don't know
them or nothing I don't know you contact
them and be like hey depends on how
successful I was it was massive 1
billion dollars yeah I try and contact
that person and be like hey I got this
idea from you yeah I don't think I would
yeah I think I would hang dumb property
that's what that's what I'm saying about
that maturity bear mature you're very
mature person trying to take care of
people if you know if they deserve it
and if you come up with a great idea
even though you did nothing to execute
it what if the ideas bother me oh yeah
especially when they do all the time
what if someone had the idea and forgive
me for stringing this out but I'm trying
to see I'm trying to identify your
threshold you seem saying what if the
idea was said by someone that you don't
know in passing and it was a joke it
wasn't even like a full idea like it was
a joke like you're like oh let's we
should invent a parachute that like can
spring a motor and take you I don't know
something kind of ridiculous but when
you thought about you're like wait wait
wait wait that's not read I could
actually do that you did it meanwhile
they're totally joking mmm in fact they
were kind of mocking it then would you
reward them you got the idea from them I
don't know I'd need more specifics on
this scenario all right but if people
hit me with good ideas I will take care
of them you know
pretty straightforward all right all
right going back to the book I can
recall a former vice president of one of
the companies with which I am associated
he would formulate some good plans but
never followed up to see that his plans
got the expected results I knew he had
served in World War two so out of
curiosity I looked into the nature of
his service and found that his entire
period of service was a staff officer he
had never had the advantage of a command
job so his training was incomplete maybe
if he had remained in the service longer
he would have developed his leadership
qualities as well and this man would
still be with the company so if you're
not able to execute things your ID this
is now see now I'm starting to get mad
because because it does bother me when
people just want to throw out ideas and
they don't push them to completion
that's that's that's unsafe right that's
fun sappy and yeah you Dave were talking
about that good deal Dave we're talking
about that - it's like a sin right yeah
I don't follow through and others so and
that is true which kind of takes me back
to what it like what about the idea guy
who's like you stole my idea right it's
like it kind of makes that thing a
little bit more angry like like it makes
you mad a little bit more when a person
is like hey that was my idea it's like
probably you're like a you're you're a
low utility person you don't execute on
anything ever and now this was your idea
and you somehow deserves like something
for the success of the idea meanwhile
you provided in my opinion less than 1%
of the ideas success yeah yeah when you
get into these hypothetical scenarios
where the person is basically not really
creating the idea for the purpose of
being executed
maybe that's the line but if you're
creating an ID and your act if you've
created an ID and you're actively trying
to get people to execute on it I'll
problem I will take care of you if
you're not even intentionally trying to
create something first of all you're you
used not know factor in the world like
how would I even know who you are you
not you don't even step up you don't
leave a trail of hay that connects you
to this idea yeah so it's no factor
actually zero factor the person's just
unset you may have heard heard this
story about General Pershing in World
War one while inspecting a certain area
he found a project that was not going
too well even though a second lieutenant
in charge seemed to have a pretty good
plan General Pershing asked lieutenant
how much pay he received and when the
lieutenant replied 140 1.67 per month
sir General Pershing said just remember
that you give get a dollar 67 for making
your plan and issuing the order and a
hundred and forty dollars for seeing
that it's carried out yeah you need
people like that and I'll tell you this
is another thing well that will go in
the next book well maybe not the next
book it'll go into the next ancient
technique book I'm gonna ancient
technique will be getting things getting
the troops to execute the plan mmm how
do you do that cuz this is again he
brushes up against these things like hey
we all know that it sucks that if your
team isn't doing what they're supposed
to do how do we actually get them to do
it yeah right one of the leadership
strategy and tactics which some of which
I do talk about in leadership strategy
and tactics how you get the people to
actually get the job done that you want
them to do and part of it has to do with
you know this guy seemed to have come up
with a pretty good plan well if you let
your troops come with the plan there's
gonna be a better chance they execute it
as we know so that might go into the
ancient ancient procedures ancient
techniques yeah remember that video that
I was in where I was talking about me
yeah yes the the ancient masters and I
said something where you said to me I
could tell you we're reaching for a word
because I said something like summon the
power he sent me the power of the and I
didn't know what I said I paid it myself
in the corner but I said the ancients
which by the way may have been brewed in
my head from Tenacious D because he's
got a did that one of their one of their
or the HBO specials they talk about the
ancients and that
what am I talking about maybe that's
exactly where it came from I had to
summon up the D they came through at the
moment of truth because those videos
that particular video mmm I for some
reason I'm a little bit more I have a
little bit more fun when I'm annoyed
[Music]
Maki min so what happened was the the
female who was prompting me with
different questions
mmm-hmm she says you know so tell me
tell me what you do to get up in the
morning and I said well what I do is I
set my alarm clock and I when it goes
off I get out of bed which is my
standard answer I give it a thousand
times and then she says no no no but she
said something along lines and she was
super cool she says something along the
lines of know what I mean I think my
producers can you give my producer more
than that mm and that's when I went into
this whole thing but it was just off the
top of my head but I got stuck for a
word and the be delivered for game
through yes so now there's gonna be a
whole book connected to that see that
levels yes yeah all right continuing on
he's so he's talking about the pershing
thing you get paid $140 you get paid a
dollar 67 for making the plan you get
paid $140 for seeing that is carried out
he says I'm not sure that I would go to
that extreme certainly in these days
problems are complex and good staff work
plays a large part about resolving them
I have known commanders who were not too
smart but they were very knowledgeable
about personnel and who knew enough to
select the very best for their staffs
remember a good leader is one who causes
or inspires others staff or subordinate
commanders to do the job boy I've known
commanders who are not too smart but
they were very knowledgeable there's I
know there's all kinds of like
literature about this kind of thing but
there's different kinds of intelligence
right mm-hm absolutely different kinds
of intelligence and one of the least
most important types of intelligence is
book-smart
when it comes to operating in the real
world one of the least least important
types of intelligence is hey I can
memorize this for a test or I can
understand these come if you can't read
people if you don't have that emotional
intelligence
if you don't able to react if you aren't
able to control your own emotions
there's a about a million things yeah so
you can be not too smart and still do
outstanding especially if you're smart
enough to go you know what I'm not that
smart but I got I got Fred over here
yeah you guess brain horsepower I'm
gonna bring him on the team yeah I'm not
gonna put him in front up in front of
the troops cuz he fumbles around with
his words but I'm gonna have him going
through my plan line by line checking
the numbers making sure we're good to go
build the right team furthermore no
leader knows it all although sometimes
you find one who seems to think he does
a leader should encourage the members of
his staff to speak up if they think
their commander is wrong he should
invite constructive criticism it is a
grave error for the leader to surround
himself with a yes staff hmm hence no
yes-men leadership strategy and tactics
do not surround yourself with yes men
speaking of ideas that have been stolen
Omar Bradley I stole that idea I guess
and put it in a book General George C
Marshall was an excellent exponent of
the principle of having his support and
speak up when he first came to chief
staff when he first became chief of
staff of the Army the Secretariat of
that office consisted of three officers
who presented orally to general Marshall
the staff papers or studies coming from
the divisions of the general staff I was
a member of that Secretariat we
presented in abbreviated form the
contents of the staff studies citing the
highlights of the problem involved the
various possible courses of actions
considered and the action recommended
the end of his first week as chief of
staff Marshall called us into his office
and opened the discussion by saying I am
disappointed in all of you when we
inquired if we might ask why he said you
haven't disagreed disagreed with a
single thing I have done all week we
told him it just so happened that we
were in full agreement with every paper
that had been presented that we knew he
wanted and that we would add our
comments to anything that we considered
should be questioned the very next day
we presented a paper as written and then
expressed some thoughts which in our own
opinion made the recommendation
recommended action questionable general
Marshall said now that is what I want
unless I hear all the arguments against
an action I am not sure whether I am
right or not you don't want to surround
yourself with those people that are just
gonna tell you that all you're right and
you you feel that or you see that with
the suit what are the celebrities right
that can surround themselves with people
that just tell them hey you're the
greatest you're super you can do
whatever you want and then you watch
them on the downward spiral of
destruction they need someone going hey
bro stop that's that's dumb I you might
be able to get away with it but it
you're not gonna get away with it for
long and it's gonna be hanging over here
like that doesn't happen they get
surrounded by people that just blindly
support them yes do you feel that it's
like I guess when you think about it
seems like a two-way street right like
the person okay so you don't want to
surround yourself with yes men right and
let's say you happen for like a better
way of putting it you happened to not
surround yourself with yes yes man it's
not like you actively were like hey
you're yes men and I don't really hang
out with Fred and he's like we'll push
back and yeah Dave yeah are you trust
him because your bullet your friend or
whatever right versus the person who's
like actively surrounding themselves
with people were not yes men right but
the to the street kind of goes where if
I'm not saying celebrities are like this
but some people in the world are like
where it's like hey and maybe they don't
consciously think of it this way they
just go by their feeling and they're
like hey this person doesn't agree with
me like all the time like this person
does and when this person agrees with me
all the time it really makes me feel
good and this is just the feeling
they're not consciously oh yeah so
you're saying you're saying that someone
may just buy a small decision after a
small decision after a small division
decision over time they just end up
getting rid of everyone that gives them
any objections yes that's exactly what
happens yeah I think that's why you have
to proactively make sure you've got
people on your team that are gonna push
back you know and I just was on the EF
on mine today I was talking about the
fact that I was hyper paranoid about
making sure I took input from other
people
there was the when the seals went into
Panama they went into bhatia airfield
was a rough oper operation lost four
seals and I worked for a guy that was
there he was he was on the boats
that that put the seals in and so he had
been through the whole planning process
and everything and I I asked him I said
you know what happened and he explained
to me that what can happen tactically on
the ground and I I was kind of okay I
get that I was I said but how did you
how did that plan because the plan
seemed like it had some some violations
of sort of fundamental like normal
tactics that seals use and he just said
that there was a couple guys that kind
of work know this is what we're gonna do
and this is what's gonna work and it
wasn't a lot of pushback against it so I
always felt that it was really critical
that you want pushback and that you
listened to it because if you know all
those seals and and you know those
heroic guys that died on that airfield
if if a plan can get through all those
guys all those seals
then we need to make sure our minds are
open and we're listening and taking
input because otherwise if you if you
come you come up with a plan that you
think is great and when you hear a
question about it you've got to listen
to the question you got to listen to the
question so it's free that's so hard
like you know when you come up with a
plan or an idea or whatever a video
whatever
and you show it to someone or you
present it and here's the thing when you
come up with a comprehensive plan that
you're happy about you're fired up you
know I know where you're going with us
and you're like saying how hard it is
III am so conditioned at this point to
be paranoid yeah and I was trying to
figure out where that came from in my
head and it came from that situation
from hearing that guy who ended up I
ended up working for hearing him
explained to me hey there wasn't enough
pushback and we went forward with a plan
that not everyone agreed with and you
think I thought to myself I'm never
gonna so at this point I come up with a
plan for anything which normally as you
know I try not to I try to let other
everybody else come up with a plan but
sometimes I do come up with a plan
hmm and I'm I'm so comfortable with
someone saying hey I don't like that
it doesn't have any impact on me
whatsoever it's so easy for me to say
actually the great point didn't think of
that yeah man that's so good because he
and you and you know you put it you're
the one who put it like this where it's
like you don't emotionally attach
yourself to the plan but I guess that's
that really the part that's hard
I watched seal platoon after seal
platoon after seal platoon get so
wrapped around the axle that plan of my
plan my plan yeah and you know normally
at the end of the day they and this is
what this is when I was running training
I would walk because I'd sit there and
watch and plan and your de facto
detached because I'm sitting back
watching them plan but you would see
them just go down the row road of
arguing with each other about my plan
versus your plan both the plans will
work fine I'll tell you what won't work
is trying to plant do the plan in 20
minutes because you've wasted four hours
arguing about what
plan is better yeah and I would see that
all the time yeah you know that yeah I
felt I'm not gonna say I've gone through
this I'm not gonna say I've not gone
through this but you know you show
someone a video that you might have made
or whatever and you're like you say hey
you know tell me what you think of this
video before you release it or something
like that
and really when you really be honest
this is what it is half of your brain is
like hey I need some feedback to make it
the best I can and let me give you a
look just so I can get some good
feedback you know on improving it that's
half the other half of your brain is
kind of like hey this is kind of the
premiere a little bit and I want to get
rewarded for my work you know with with
you know praise and hopefully applause
or something you know kind of like that
so it's like your two sides of your
brain so one that when it when you do
have get feedback where it's like hey I
would improve this I would do this or at
that beginning got to change it or
whatever that that second part of your
brain is kind of like bro why did I even
show it to you like you're not even
[__] being cool about it you know
kind of kind of an attitude you know
that was the part once again this is
where humility is so important because
otherwise you just don't improve
anything okay if I show someone a piece
of writing and they go yeah you know I
like this but you could do this
different I'm like okay cool and
sometimes I just wrote a piece and I
sent it to one of my editors and look
let's say they wrote a hundred things
well let's say they wrote 50 things of
the 50 things that they wrote I accepted
I don't know 93 percent of them there
was one major change the only the most
significant change in the piece and I
said hey I appreciate the feedback I'm
not changing that thing and it wasn't
cause of Eagle is like okay I read it
five times and said you know what that
absolutely needs to be in there and I
saw her perspective and said you know
what I get where she's coming from but
this ties everything together
and I think that's what I didn't do a
good job explaining to her
but yes you have to at least be open to
it you have to at least be open to it
yeah yeah it meeting to yourself that
you're like and go into it with the
attitude of hey I have to actually
strongly be able to defend my position
and if I can't defend my position then
you're probably right
right like on a logical level almost
yeah not like hey that wasn't cool you
put down that my writing you know like
not that at it yeah you know my just
like I say well my goal is to listen to
if you and I are working together and
I'm in charge and we're gonna attack a
target my goal is to have you come up
with a plan that's my absolute goal when
you come to me with a plan I'm not
looking at it what's wrong with I'm
saying what's right with it mmm I like
it I like your plan better than what I
thought I was gonna think when you bring
me a piece of when I bring you a piece
of writing and you give me feedback my
goal is to go okay your feedback is
correct and I'm wrong and unless it just
pains me to change something then I'm
gonna lean towards your recommendation
yeah
that's such a good way to look at it
it's like you're writing or whatever
your completed work that you need
feedback on it's like you just if you go
in automatically regarding it as this
there's a problem with this there's
holes in this it's missing stuff and it
has too much of some other stuff yeah I
know that for a fact and it that upsets
me I'm gonna go to this person and they
can identify them these things that's it
yeah not how awesome it is it's like
there's a problem with this and I need
this problem to be solved in this person
consultant I was listening to Brian
Koppelman on Tim Ferriss podcast Brian
Koppelman and David Levine are the
writers of the show billions yes sir
have you heard of this show I have I
hear good things but it was interesting
because Brian compliment I wish I could
remember exactly what he said well
there's two things that he said number
one if he's gonna give somebody
something for feedback on something that
he's written you don't give you don't
give someone their completed project and
say hey can you give me some feedback on
this cuz I already finished it what
you're really asking if I say hey echo I
wrote this book can you give me some
feedback on it
yeah that's sort of it's sort of a bad
thing I have to say hey echo this is
just a draft yeah okay and then he had
some response of saying something like
do you want do you want me to read it
or do you want feedback yet some way of
saying hey write you want me to really
go to town on this thing or you just
want me to read it you just want me to
watch this video that you made or do you
want feedback I wish I could think of we
said something something you know do you
want professional feedback or something
like that it's something that was hey
look if I give this to you straight it's
gonna sting yeah that's the man that's
so good because it's almost like there
because there are two different people
there two different roles you're asking
this person to be are you do you want
this person to be an audience member the
exact fan or do you or your tradition
critic or editor what or assistant what
it you know you want yeah so it's like
just two different attitudes and that's
oh yeah that's like the emotional you go
part versus the you know the technician
or whatever the other guy is yeah so
those are you've gotta get that humble
brain going if you want to ask people
for feedback in anything and it stings
every single time is the way it works
going back to the book if you happen to
be a detail detail to a staff try and be
a good staff officer and if possible
avoid being a yes-man I would suggest to
all commanders that they inform the
members of their staffs that anyone who
does not agree once in a while with what
is about to be done is of limited value
and perhaps should be shifted to some
other place where he might occasionally
have an idea so if you're just an
agreement I'm I don't need you I don't
need you yeah of course I'm thinking
about the decision-making process after
a decision is made everyone must be 100%
behind it I thought the British were
admirable in this respect er in World
War two no matter how much discussion
there had been on a subject as
the decision was made you never heard
any doubts expressed you had to believe
that everyone involved in making that
decision had never entertained any ideas
except those expressed in this decision
you know how I used to explain this to
the young junior officers because I used
to say once a decision is made you
execute it as if it was your own now
here's where people will freak out about
that right they freaked out about that
because they think but what if I don't
really agree with it
if you don't really agree with it check
a couple things number one if echo comes
up with a plan and you're my boss and
you're telling me how we're gonna do
something and I'm like no we need to do
it this way the first thing I need to
check it finally like no we're doing it
this way that's the decision we're going
forward the first thing I need to check
is what do you think it is take it yes
yes I need to check my ego because I
would say upwards of 90% 90% of the time
the only reason I disagree is because of
my ego because I got some little ID and
I think my way would be better and even
if my way is better it's not drastically
better because we're both fighting for
the same cause right how often is it a
boss is like hey we want to execute this
way and someone says hey that's the
really horrible way to do it's gonna be
unsafe for the team members and it's
gonna not it's gonna lose money and the
boss because I don't care no we're doing
it my way no he goes wait wait a second
what are you talking about explain this
to me how is it unsafe and how are we
gonna lose money so the idea is first
thing you check is is it my ego that's
preventing me from accepting this new
idea what are the degrees of variance
between my idea and the way it's
actually happening because if the
degrees of variance are minimal then
shut up and go and execute the plan as
if it was your own now if there are
significant degrees of variance where
it's gonna be a really bad situation I
hate to use the word catastrophic but
certainly if you see a catastrophic
problem then you go hey we cannot do
this this is not good and you you don't
go forward if it's gonna be catastrophic
or again going back to leadership
strategy taxes and you got
then you've got to figure out is it
better for me to go ahead with it but
now I can go mitigate the damage
mitigate the risk as much as possible
that might be what you have to do so
that idea of executing as if you believe
it as if it's your own which is what you
should do you you need to have those
conversations listen put your ego in
check and then if it's close enough you
go Roger that boss I'm on board with the
plan let's go execute it and you do
execute it as if it's your own yeah no
factor continuing on I don't want to
overemphasize leadership of senior
officers so he doesn't want to just talk
about senior officers my interest
extends to the leaders of all ranks I
would cost you to remember that an
essential qualification of a good leader
is the ability to recognize select and
train junior officers I would like to
quote from a book entitled to born a
trevally written by Colonel read reader
Colonel reader was on a trip for general
marshal and one of his assignments was
to inquire into junior leadership this
is an account of his conversation with
Colonel Bryant more on guadalcanal quote
Colonel Moore I said tell me something
about leadership I had hit a sensitive
spot Colonel Moore forged ahead
leadership the greatest problem here is
the leaders and you have to find some
way to weed out the weak ones it is
tough to do this when you're in combat
the platoon leaders who cannot command
who cannot foresee things and who cannot
act on the spur of the moment in an
emergency or a distinct detriment so
this is clear right we know this but
there you have it reinforced for the one
millionth time if you've got weak
leaders you're gonna have problems
if you can't command if you can't
foresee things and if you can't act on
the spur of the moment you're gonna have
problems
when's the last time you heard that's a
negative thing right oh he acts on the
spur of the moment actually there's some
times where you need to do that he
continues on it's hot here as you can
see men struggle they get heat
exhaustion they come out vomiting and
throwing away equipment the leaders must
be leaders and they must be alert enough
to establish straggler lines and stop
this thing and I need to do I try to
research this a an order the book if the
book is actually for sale
it's called born in revelry it got some
interesting reviews it seems like a good
book whether they say I guess it's I
guess it's written in some offensive
language in modern era so but I cuz I
wasn't really a 100% the leaders must be
leaders and that they must be alert
enough to establish straggler lines and
stop this thing I guess he's talking
about heat exhaustion right he must be
straggler lines are lines of people that
aren't ready to fight and stop this
thing I'm assuming he's talking about
the heat exhaustion so it goes on the
and this is why I think that's what it
means the men have been taught to take
salt tablets but leaders don't see to
this result heat exhaustion the good
leaders seem to get killed the poor
leaders get the men killed the big
problem is leadership and getting the
shoulder straps on the right people and
then the book continues sixty millimeter
mortars mortar shells fell about thirty
yards away and attacked a number of
coconut trees I lost interest in taking
dictation and the colonel stopped
talking when the salvo was over and
things were quiet again Bryant Moore
said where was I you saw that patrol I
tell you this not one man in fifty can
lead a patrol in this jungle if you can
find out who the good patrol leaders are
before you hit the combat zone you have
found out something now what's
interesting about that is first of all
one man in fifty can lead a patrol in
this jungle that's and that's a
significant statement if you and and I
will tell you says if you can find out
who the good patrol leaders are before
you hit the combat zone you found out
something how do you do that you do that
by putting them in these pressure
situations we had such a benefit our
guys were so ready we put these guy we
put I put my I put the seals going on
deployment through training like that
where you could see them
break you could see them not be able to
handle it or what's more important they
wouldn't be able to handle it day one
day two they'd be a little better day
three they to be a little bit better day
for they'd be a little bit better by the
end of a six month to work up they're
actually one of the people that can make
these make these things happen so it's
not just about finding the good patrol
leaders it's about training them he says
I have to get rid of about twenty five
officers because they just I've had to
get rid of about twenty five officers
because they just weren't leaders I had
to make the battalion commander weed out
the poor leaders this process of
continuous other junior leaders are
finding out that they must know more
than their men more about their men the
good leaders know their men of
everything he talks about he says the
thing that he gives that you must know
your men that's the thing that that's
the that's the one thing he doesn't say
they need a navigation they need to work
under fire he said they need to know
their men very interesting thing to
focus on for for this guy talking for
general more talking about this or
Colonel Moore but I will tell you that
having to get rid of about twenty five
officers I'm gonna go ahead out on a
limb here and I don't know how many
officers he went through but some of
those officers could who could have been
trained could have been trained could
have been prepared could have been
molded it could have been could have
been educated could have been tested
prior to going into combat and he
probably would have done better than
then having to get rid of 25 of them
mm-hmm continuing on what then or the
characteristic wala T's of a leader
there are many essential characteristics
that he must possess but I will mention
a few that come to mind as perhaps the
most important first he must know his
job without necessarily being a
specialist in any in every phase of it a
few years ago has suggested that all
engineers all engineering subjects be
eliminated from the required studies at
West Point I objected for example bridge
building is especially for engineers yet
I think every senior
officer should have some idea of what is
involved when we reached the Rhine in
World War two it was not necessary that
I know how to build a bridge but it was
very helpful that I knew what was
involved so that I could see the bridge
engineers receive proper support in
tonnage allowed and an idea of the time
involved so so first know your job you
know everything about it I didn't know
the sniper weapons as good as the
snipers did I didn't know the radio as
good as the radio man did I didn't know
the route as good as the point man did
but I knew enough about them
continuing on specialties dominate
almost every problem faced by the
military today by the butt-faced today
by the military leader or the business
manager this individual must get deeply
enough into his problem that he can
understand it and intelligently manage
it without going so far as to become a
specialist himself in every phase of the
problem you don't have to be a tank
expert in order to effectively use a
tank unit of your command Thomas J
Watson of IBM once said that the genius
of an executive is the ability to deal
successfully with matters he does not
understand this leads to another
principle of leadership which I have
often found neglected both in the
military and in business while you need
to be a specialist in all phases of your
job you should have a proportionate
degree of interest in every aspect of it
and those concerned your subordinates
should be aware of your interest so you
you should be interested in what is
happening you must get around and show
interest in what your subordinates are
doing even if you don't know much about
the technique of their work and you make
these when you are making these visits
try to pass out praise when do as well
as corrections or criticism that's an
interesting one it's very interesting
what Omar Bradley points out here that
that hey not only should you know what's
happening but you should you should show
interest in what your supporters doing
you know how I would translate that and
I would call it building relationships
building relationships what he's talking
about mmm he's talking about building
relationships showing interest being out
there yeah
building relationships with your troops
again I I think a lot of times in this
in this speech he's he's either brushing
up or he's using his own verbiage to
cover to to talk about the same things
that we talk about all the time the same
things that I write about all the time
continuing on we tend to speak up only
when things go wrong this is such a well
recognized fact that a complaint
department isn't it's an essential part
of many business firms to my knowledge
no comparable facility exists anywhere
to expedite the handling of praise for a
job well done that need not be
extravagant we all get enough criticism
and we learn to take it even Sir Winston
Churchill despite his matchless
accomplishment found occasion to say I
have benefited enormous Lee from
criticism and at no point did I suffer
from any perceptible lack thereof but
let us remember that praise also has a
role to play
Napoleon was probably the finest
exponent of this principle of
recognition through his use of a quarter
inch of ribbon to improve the morale and
get results so interesting that Bradley
is very focused on praise very
interesting that he's focused on praise
you can see what kind of a different guy
he is than Patton and by the way I
forgot to say this his book much of the
movie Patton the famous movie Oscar
award-winning movie Patton sure it was a
lot of it was based on on on that book
that he wrote a soldier story because
two different philosophies ray with the
praise things yeah you know you just you
just get the feeling that Omar Bradley
was a little bit well a lot more a lot
more humble a lot more you know open and
and and probably hate good job buddy
where you don't expect Patton to say hey
good job buddy unless it's some crazy
situation how will the top soldier right
but eww picture Omar Bradley going hey
nice work on that that was good you
don't really so I'm just saying it so
it's an
same thing for him to see and on yeah
the it feels like like this I mean it
maybe goes with different personalities
or whatever but okay so on one hand you
have the guy who's always saying good
job one's good job but offering
corrections when necessary to I can't
get out of here so they're essentially
it's almost like you're constantly in
touch with how they're feeling about you
kind of thing as a worker or as whatever
yeah um so it's like it'll be like good
job every every little thing is either a
good job or hey you could do this a
little bit better every single little
thing right so it's like you kind of
know where you stand it's kind of
comforting I guess in that way but at
the same time it's kind of like when do
you know when you really did a good job
you don't really know as much you're not
totally in touch but the opposite the
other guy who did he doesn't say
anything you do a little good job you
won't hear nothing ever you'll know
about the corrections for sure but they
tend and I'm speaking from experience
more than anything they tend to be like
big Corrections if you have to make a
you know cuz it's not if it's no factor
Corrections or it's like a you know
whatever like fine it's a 80% solution
and it's cool whatever meanwhile they
don't say much is what I'm saying until
something's a big deal good or bad so
really it kind of makes you want to
strive to get that big compliment you
know more so than so it's less
comforting I guess day to day but at the
same time it's almost like this
intangible like motivation to do a good
job for this guy you know you're gonna
seemed like that yeah it's it's a
dichotomy that's got to be balanced you
don't want to go overboard you don't be
complaining every little thing you want
to pop on every little thing either I
would say you are correct it's better to
back off a little bit and have your have
your compliments or your criticisms be
worthy of either one of those things
smaller Corrections more often or easier
to give then big Corrections when people
aren't used to see kind of condition
someone right you can condition someone
and it's good to do this if if if I
condition someone where they expect like
hey some some pretty straightforward
feedback that's a totally positive thing
if you're not conditioned to it and all
of a sudden I hammer you with something
it's a blow yeah you know it hurts and
it might even make you defensive but if
I'm constantly not constantly to the
point of being annoying but if I'm on a
regular basis I'm telling you oh echo
you know can you adjust this thing when
you when you put these things out or hey
echo when you when you get when you get
done with a project that report needs to
have more detail in it okay well the
more I correct you and again I gotta be
careful
can't go overboard but I gotta get your
condition to where you understand that I
am going to give you some some feedback
mm-hmm some negative feedback about what
you're doing don't want to harp on you
it's really hard to tell right because a
lot of times people just sit there and
take any go home and kick their dog
because I'm mad at their boss all right
the next little characteristic of a
leader he says both mental and physical
energy are essential to successful
leadership how many really good leaders
have you known who were lazy or weak or
who couldn't stand the strain Sherman
was a good example of a leader without
standing mental and physical energy
I cite him with some trepidation because
some of you may be from Georgia however
during the advance from Chattanooga to
Atlanta he often went for days with only
two hours of sleep per night and was
constantly in the saddle doing
reconnaissance and he often knew the
dispositions and terrain so well that he
could maneuver the enemy out of position
without a serious fight and with minimal
losses so general Tecumseh Sherman who
marched who did his march to the sea 100
million dollars worth of damage in
Georgia as he kind of destroyed things
as he went but showing that he had this
high level of energy continues
conversely a sick commander is of
limited value it is not fair to the
troops under him to have a leader who is
not functioning a hundred percent
I had to relieve several senior
commanders during World War two because
of illness
it's often pointed out that Napoleon
didn't lose a major battle until
Waterloo where he was a sick man a
leader should possess human
understanding and consideration for
others men are not robots and should not
be treated as though they were machines
I did not by any means suggest coddling
there's another example of dichotomy
right don't treat him as if of machines
but don't coddle but men are highly
intelligent complicated beings who will
respond favorably to human understanding
and consideration by this means their
leader will get maximum effort from each
of them you will also get loyalty and in
this connection it will is well to
remember that loyalty goes down as well
as up the sincere leader will go to bat
for subordinates when such action is
needed
pretty straightforward dichotomy right
there a good leader must sometimes be
stubborn Here I am reminded of the West
Point cadet prayer and far that prayer
says a leader must be able to choose the
harbor right instead of the easier wrong
armed with the courage of his
convictions he must fight to defend them
then he has then he has to come to a
decision after thorough analysis and
when he is sure he is right he must
stick to it even to the point of
stubbornness grant furnaces a good
illustration of this trait he never knew
when he was supposed to be licked a less
stubborn man might have lost at Shiloh
by the way Shiloh 24,000 dead in two
days total nightmare
maybe you've heard the story of General
Grant in Richmond campaign when after
being up all night making his
reconnaissance and formulating and
issuing orders he laid down and fell
asleep under a tree some time later a
courier wrote up and informed general
and formed the general that disaster had
hit his right flank and that his troops
at the end of the line were in full
retreat General Grant sat up shook his
head to clear the cobwebs and said it
can't be so and went back to sleep and
it wasn't so he had confidence in
himself and in his subordinate leaders
a little hard for me to accept that one
I may give a little bit more attention
if someone come tells me of my flank is
collapsing but the point being he had
confidence hey we're gonna be alright
yeah see that seemed like a little tail
I mean obviously I don't know if that's
true or not I'm assuming it's true but
it seemed like more of an exaggerated
tale like straight up sleeping yeah
straight up there's a picture of Dave
Burke and I'm good deal T yes where I
think we're putting in Combat Outpost
Falcon in downtown Ramadi yeah and the
picture is probably I don't even know
when the pictures taken but we're both
asleep they were both of us sitting up
against the wall we're both asleep we
probably honestly awake for 24 hours at
this point is the commander of salt one
six yes all six he's he was a lightning
one six and and I was the commander of
task unit bruiser and we're both just
racked out yeah we're in the but we're
in the combat outpost the combat outpost
is was now secure there's a bunch of
guys from the 137 army just surrounding
this thing and build it out and we did
get some sleep so apparently we did yeah
yeah sleeping gets a bad rap I guess now
that you kind of mention it you know how
sleeping on the job
sleeping on a job that's not a good
expression like that expression is not a
positive expression yes like hey if
you're sleeping on the job you're not
doing a good job yeah but if you
yeah actually lave talks about the
student life like as soon as he would
get into an overwatch position get it
set up and get security set evey that
cool I'm gonna say cuz yeah the planning
cycle for for like us officers going
into the field we would be planning
basically the whole time ready to go in
we would know that once we got in the
field we could get some sleep
yeah because there's no chain of command
breathing down your neck for another
CONOPS
submission you're just out there your
call yeah brother free but if you're a
sleep-deprived a lot of times you know
you no good to nobody yeah I do you know
what I'm not 100% on board with that I'm
just being straight up like you
there's there's I mean I read some
things that say you know if you've if
you've missed if you haven't slept for
24 hours it's the equivalent of three
you're you're legally drunk mm-hmm
I don't think so yeah sure there's
there's times I'll tell you what's a
good example the early musters that we
did when we were doing the musters we
were we didn't we didn't have a system
down yet and so we didn't know all the
things that we're gonna have to tackle
we were just we just didn't prepare
correctly and so we laugh and I would be
up and all night long I think the worst
muster as far as sleep goes was New York
City New York City one of the nights I
think was the first night we had to sign
whatever nine hundred graduation
certificates it was 1:30 in the morning
when we got started PT by the way for us
starts at 3:00 so we sat there we signed
him we went to bed for now we woke up
that next day we're on stage the entire
day no stopping people riddling
questions at me people what about this
what about that Papa now could I have
done that if I was seven drinks drunk
some people get well and I guess they
let me let me rephrase that let's not
compare to alcohol because we know
functionally you could pull that off but
to say that I was up there cognitively
impaired right I don't think it's I
don't think you could say that yeah I
don't think it's true I think the
reality of it is that different people
are different and it's gonna affect
people in different ways and generally
speaking you know getting adequate rest
is better than not getting has no doubt
we'll take we would love to get that big
old sleep yeah that's great but what I'm
saying is people don't always get to
sleep a lot and you still have to make
critical decisions and your mind just
like your body can adapt to certain
situations when I'm doing something hmm
it doesn't matter how tired I'm I know
what's happening I'm a mom on here right
yeah so you know it's interesting the
okay so there is I'm not gonna I don't
know the studies but
if you believe that you got enough sleep
it affects your capacity so like that
almost suggests like man if you're just
like I'm gonna be TF through this
hundred percent oh yeah and that's your
attitude that will help your cognitive
capacity even if you didn't get that
much sleep and I think I meant more than
anything where it's like I don't mean
you're no good to nobody when you're you
know sleep-deprived I'm saying it's a
good attitude to have to make sure like
your team or whatever isn't
sleep-deprived that's a good attitude to
have you know but as an individual or
team member whatever it's good to be
able to function we're asleep in with
though for sure yes you do need to be
able to sleep sleep is preferred but
what I'm saying is it's not gonna you
can step up and rise to the occasion
look I don't recommend it for sure you
want to be able to sleep yes but I'm not
drastically cognitively impaired at the
moment you know we're all of a sudden
wait a second
you know I don't know what they answer
that question is uh hold on you know
that doesn't happen it doesn't happen
your adrenaline flows you're up there
you're we you pull the trigger on your
gun your whatever things are happening
if you get in the game yeah you get in
the game you know you know falling apart
oh no you're making things happen even
hey you come to the mustard that you
operate on very little sleep at the
muster especially the early ones yeah I
see you you know hey I forgot to press
record you don't maybe haven't been
paying attention as much as you could've
been in that case Jack alright continue
on I do not mean to infer that there is
always just one solution to a problem
usually there is one best solution but
any good plan both be executed is better
than indecision there's more there's
usually more than one way to obtain
results and the most important thing
about that little section right here
look we know that's the same thing pat
and says any good plan Bowlby actually
is better than indecision or a good
on his patents say a good plan executed
now is better than a great plan executed
next week saying they're saying the same
thing there's usually more than one way
to obtain results I like that I want to
focus on that because again I'm not
arguing with you about six and one half
dozen the other I'm not arguing with you
about should we bring six vehicles or
five vehicles I'm not arguing with you
if we should if we should invest you
know eight hundred thousand dollars in
this market or seven hundred and forty
thousand dollars in this market I'm not
arguing those things what's the outcome
gonna be they were gonna be pretty close
this more than one way to skin a cat
cool let's go let's rock and roll and by
the way when you come up with a plan and
you and I go you know what echo let's do
it let's let's do what you say and we
start going down that road it's not like
we're stuck there and I go hey echo it
looks like your plan might not be
working out that great let's make an
adjustment you go cool sounds good and
by the way you're more open to hearing
my suggestions if I was originally open
to your suggestions in the first place I
built a little relationship there mm-hmm
working on multiple fronts continuing on
another quality of leadership that comes
to mind is self-confidence you must have
confidence in yourself your unit and
your subordinate commanders and in your
plan this recalls a couple of instance
just before the invasion of Normandy
1944 story went around in some of the
units that were making the assault on
the beaches that they would suffer 100%
casualties that none of them would come
back I found it necessary to visit these
units and talk to all ranks I told them
that of course we would suffer
casualties but certainly our losses
would be less would not be a hundred
percent and that with our air and naval
support we would succeed after our
landing a correspondent told me that on
his way across the channel in one of the
leading LSTs he had a known as a
sergeant reading a novel struck by this
seeming lack of concern by the sergeant
he said he asked aren't you worried how
can you be reading at a time like this
the sergeant replied no I'm not worried
general Bradley said everything would go
alright so why should I worry I can't
recall just what I had said but it
accomplished its purpose
at least where one man was concerned I
might relate another incident where
there was a lack of confidence I had to
relieve a senior commander because I
learned that his men had lost confidence
in him
this meant of course that we would not
expect maximum performance by that
division after being relieved the
officer came back through my
headquarters and showed me a file of
statements given to him by request I am
sure by the burgomaster of all the towns
his division had passed through if he
had confidence in himself he would not
have felt the need for all those letters
that's a cool little story so he fires
this division commander and the division
commander comes out and says listen I
haven't been doing a bad job here's the
mayors of all the cities that we've been
through here's they told me I did a good
job here look at the letters and he's
like and he actually goes on after
seeing the letters I told the officer
that if I ever had any doubts as to
whether to relieve him those doubts were
now removed his letters proved beyond
question that he had lost confidence in
himself so it was no wonder that the men
had lost confidence in him so definitely
confidence is important the interesting
thing is humility which is chapter 2 in
extreme ownership check your ego became
an army value in 2019 and which is
awesome but I also he talks about
confidence that's what he talks about he
never really explores what happens when
you get overconfident right and we all
know that you can get overconfident you
can lose so that's why humility is
important he says here next
characteristic a leader must possess
imagination whether it be an
administrative decision or one made in
combat the possible results of that
decision must be plain to the one making
it what will the next step be and the
one after that
that's all he gives to imagination
that's all he gives to creativity need a
little bit more
while there are many other qualities
which can contribute to effective
leadership I will mention just one more
but it is a very important one character
this word has many meanings I am
applying it in a broad sense to describe
a person who has high ideals who stands
by them and who can be absolutely
trusted such a person will be respected
by all those with whom he is associated
and such a person will readily be
recognized by his associates for what he
is
circumstances mould our character these
circumstances affect different people in
different ways from exactly the same set
of circumstances
one man may theoretically build a palace
while another may have difficulty
building a lean-to a lean-to it's a
little hot little meat love the roof
leans up against a stick I'll put some
dick and put some put some leaves on top
of it to keep you dry that's called a
lean-to so from the same experiences one
person builds a palace the other person
built a lean-to hmm that's a rough one
to take too rough on the take coz you
might look around and say well you know
I didn't have the right circumstances in
my life to be successful I promise you
that there's someone with worse
circumstances that's more successful
than you promised you promised you
believe it has been said that a man's
character is the reality of himself I
don't think a man's strength of
character ever changes I remember a long
time ago when somebody told me that a
mountains Mountain might be reported to
have moved I could believe it or
disbelieve it as I wished but if anyone
told me that a man had changed his
character I should not believe it I
don't know look I think it's hard for
people's characters to change I don't
think you can change someone's character
very easily actively proactively make
their character change
but I think that through life and
through experience people's character
does absolutely change yeah and you can
meet someone now that you knew 10 years
ago
and you'd say whoa that person is a
whole new character and you would mean
character yeah it's classic sense yeah
well I mean what and to kind of to kind
of identify what is character do you
think like he what just kind of morale
like your fiber you know it's not cuz
it's not like you can talk to pretty
much anyone and they'd probably tell you
yeah like I'm a different person than I
was 15 years ago pretty much ever be
like okay that wouldn't be a big
surprise or whatever but they're not
talking about that right like character
is different well they are talking about
that what he's saying is that you know
that slimy guy that you knew in high
school that was trying to screw people
over and whatever yeah he's saying like
that guy when youse meet him
20 years later guess what he's doing
still a solid guy let's do another right
I disagree with that I actually have
known people whose character has changed
and for me I mean there's a we could do
a whole show I guess about what his
character but like for me characters
doing what you're you know you're
supposed to do yeah look actually doing
what you know you're supposed to do
doing what you know is the right thing
to do yeah that's that's that's how you
end up with character right I'm just say
you're gonna do something you do it you
know you're supposed to do behave a
certain way regardless of anyone's
watching regardless of the outcome you
know you're supposed to do the right
thing you do it that's character yeah I
agree with you I think that it's a rare
thing I do kind of agree with him the
rare thing about it yeah there's some
people you guys I remember that greasy
dude yeah just being all trying to you
know get one take care of himself and
you look at that person ten years later
it's the same dudes but occasionally
yeah it's someone that changes yeah like
through maybe some big impactful event
or maybe or maybe even just like a new
influence in life in maybe like a little
revelation kind of [__] like ray you can
die oh yeah that can't happen I think
now I think it kind of does happen on
these teeny tiny ways but nothing that
would kind of collectively be considered
character
you know but I think yeah I think people
can yeah I I absolutely think they can I
think it yeah I I've seen it yeah I've
seen it yes sir
I know people where I you know you used
to look at him ago he Shh and now I look
at him totally solid yeah I mean I I
don't know how much my characters change
but absolutely it has changed you know
I'm a different guy than I was when I
was 22 yeah yeah maybe in the mate on
the battlefield maybe it's it's more
rare you know like we're to the point
where he's writing straight up it can't
be changed
yeah it's it's it's strange that he's so
I mean saying it's he'd more believed
that a mountain move than someone's
character moved that's a really bold
thing and look I got plenty of examples
where I know someone when they were you
know 15 and then 20 and then 25 and 30
and it's the same guy yeah the whole
time sometimes it's a person's justice
as upstanding in their character the
whole time
and sometimes it's they go or sometimes
they're just a scumbag from day one and
you're like I am now that's didn't
expect much much less than that and then
there's some people that progress and
there's some people that that regress
right some people get treated bad they
go through and their character goes down
yeah so I think we're in mutual
disagreement with General Omar Bradley
on this point I think people's character
can absolutely improve and I think I
think you can get worse as well you know
somebody gets what's that burned yeah
right you get burned by someone you get
burned by a girl you get burned by one
of your friends
that'll change your character yeah yeah
kind of the same deal right some big
like revelation you know or some big
impactful event or the wrong influence
over time like this is over time and
time thing you know you start hanging
around with other wrong people get into
drugs or something like this you know or
it's kind of like man my whole life is
like if you don't lie and cheat and
steal you kind of don't live you know
you kind of don't survive kinda in this
environment something like that yeah
that wouldn't make sense to you
check all these rap that's the last
characteristic he talks about all
leaders must possess these qualities
which I have been discussing and the
great leaders are those who protect
possess one or more of them to an
outstanding degree some leaders just
miss being great because they are weak
in one or more of these areas there's
still another ingredient in this formula
for a great leader that I have left out
and that is lock all caps
he must have opportunity then of course
when opportunity knocks he must be able
to rise and open the door
cool I mean look yes absolutely
I've been extremely lucky I've seen
people be extremely lucky
I've seen people been unlucky so luck
absolutely plays a role I will say you
make your own luck to an extent luck is
a tough one I no one wants to and it's
it's but it's a double-edged sword right
it's a double-edged sword because you
either of that guy got lucky right you
didn't see how hard that guy works right
or that guy got unlucky you didn't see
what that person did to end up in that
unlucky spot yeah and both those things
can flip and they're both true yeah yeah
man yeah it's it gets real complicated
and luck thing yeah I mean I talk about
in leadership strategy tactics I talk
about the luck that I had in the SEAL
Teams all kinds of luck yeah all kinds
of luck for sure just the people I
worked with the deployments that I did
the situations that I was in there's a
lot of luck there some of that luck I
manufactured some of it but just
straight up all caps no but then it's
like at the same time you can be like
well even in a great result
like a scenario with a great result you
could have been even more lucky there
possible you know so it's like
especially when you want to point
finger and you know and be like then not
point your finger but you want to put
your finger on a certain result and be
like oh this was lucky brother it's just
way more to it than that like you get
there there are better results better
that were possible yes right so you just
chose to point your finger at this very
specific result to be like this was
lucky and then and then it's a spectrum
you could have been like one level less
lucky and still had a great result kind
of thing and and then it goes down from
there and it can go up from there too so
it's like to anytime to label it luck as
the thing I mean there are extreme
scenarios for sure oh yeah like you win
the lottery that's lucky yeah
technically in a self does wrong yeah
yeah yeah it's not the whole deal at all
and it's just like it's like if you you
got a let's say this luck is a factor
but it is a smaller factor than most
people give it credit for though like
you said there are times where people
just get lucky oh yeah massively lucky
and then you have to evaluate like what
specific result are you talking about
because if it's like okay this person
has a twenty million dollars in is a
bank in his bank account that in and of
itself is the the result right of some
something right now you can start
evaluating okay was it hard work and
then with that hard work it's like okay
what la is their luck in that hardware
kind of thing or did they just win the
lottery
okay that's money you know there's a big
lucky thing kind of thing but you're
just talking about the 20 million
dollars in the account you're not
talking about his whole life you're not
talking about any of that you're just
talking about a very specific scenario
so that's what I think sometimes people
get jammed up and they'll evaluate this
whole big resulting scenario not a
specific element in it a big resulting
scenario this person whatever you know
successful in this way right and they're
like oh yeah it's just it's he just got
lucky but Brett you're you're talking
about that success has so many different
elements in it good and bad by the way
and then you just wrap up goal thing and
deliver a luck luck most likely a minor
impact but it is an impact and there are
when it's a significant impact oh yeah
but yeah it's like it's it's straight up
or most the time any when you hear it
it's straight up negating every other
factor oh and people when people say oh
that guy's lucky lucky for sure for sure
when someone's trying to make excuses
for themselves on why this person got
this promotion and I didn't know they
were lucky yeah
is there no luck involved no there's
some luck involved but let's not leave
it to luck continue on some may ask why
do you talk about the qualities of
leadership they maintain that you either
have leadership or you don't that
leaders are born not made
I suppose some are born with a certain
amount of leadership frequently we see
children who are who seem inclined to
take charge and direct their playmates
the other youngsters follow these
directions without protest but I am
convinced nevertheless that leadership
can be developed and improved by study
and training 100% there is no better way
to develop leadership than to give the
youngster or other individual a job
involving responsibility and let him try
to work it out try to avoid telling him
how to do it he's talking about
youngsters as you've heard as I talk
about leadership strategy and tactics
this is a technique it's a technique to
make people better leaders put them in
leadership situations give them
responsibility give them a job give me a
task something they can do make them
lead it they lead it they're successful
their confidence goes up then he says
tried avoiding how to telling them how
to do it yeah that's decentralized
command that for example is the basis
for a whole system of combat orders yes
combat hours they're talking actually
talking about something very specific
it's it is a way of delivering orders
using commander's intent as opposed to
telling you here's the mission here's
the people here's the weapons here's
everything here's exactly I want you to
instead you just give them the mission
you let them figure it out they call
that combat orders well tell the
subordinate we tell the subordinate
commander what we want him to do and
leave him to the details I think this
system is largely responsible for the
many
fine leaders in our services today we
are constantly training and developing
younger officers and teaching them how
to accept responsibility however don't
discount experience someone may remind
you that Napoleon led armies before he
was 30 and Alexander the Great died at
the age of 33 Napoleon as he grew older
commanded even larger armies Alexander
might have been even greater had he
lived longer and had more experience in
this respect I like I especially like
general Buckner's theory that judgment
comes from experience and experience
comes from bad judgment and he wraps it
up here I've been asked to speak on
leadership in the past I have fairly
well covered these same thoughts with
other groups somehow however at the
moment these thoughts take on added
significance for me you see my first
great grandson was born a year ago we
call him fat Henry what happens to his
life and to the lives of his
contemporaries may well be in your hands
thank you so it's a poignant kind of way
to to wrap it up the fact that the the
leaders right now that are listening to
this the leaders that are learning the
leaders that are reading they will end
up running the world and they will end
up running it well and making it better
or running it bad and making it worse
for Fat Henry so interesting interesting
I'm sure we'll get to his book at some
point but so much about leadership so
many things you know that we hit we
cover we see it from a different angle
makes you better makes me better make
better every time I get to the
opportunity to think through these
things yeah and of course only the best
way to train leaders is to make sure
that we are being good leaders ourselves
setting a good example the best example
that we can staying on the path you
might say so since we are looking to
stay on the path mm-hmm anything you
recommend echo Charles for that conduct
well we do want to keep ourselves
capable improve the skills increase the
skills one skill being jiu-jitsu it's
important skill to increase and maintain
our capability jiu-jitsu one of them
keep working out if you're not working
out work out the weak body is an
incapable body in a matter of speaking
and that is true you definitely want to
be as strong as you can't different for
everybody
yes realistic but be the be the best
shape that you can be in that's good
advice it can't really be denied can't
be so when we're doing jiu-jitsu
we need Aggie we need rash guards get an
origin key because they're the best
hundred-percent factually sound America
in America you know okay good are we
blowing that off now main America's not
a big deal anymore
oh no no America a bigger deal than ever
I think because we have an American
supply chain yeah what's going on oh
yeah so what ranking sure cuz it seemed
to me like you were just getting ready
to move on oh no without saying man
Neverland
okay hey I understand your feedback
thank you for main America's a big deal
huge deal it was a big deal prior to the
virus you know now it's an even bigger
deal Americans supply chain we're not
we're not begging and pleading for stuff
to get shipped overseas we have it's
made in America all of it yes sir so and
by the way it's not just jujitsu either
jeans you probably need jeans yes sir Oh
what does every one of the
the entire world where teens yes every
single person in the entire world needs
jeans has jeans hmm
why not kid jeans that are made in
America why not get the best and most
comfortable jeans ever made that's my
question
yeah no reason why not um so go to
origin name the state Maine or Jemaine
common is where you can get all this
stuff okay so all this stuff that I'm
talking about like Jocko so eloquently
put it he's made in America from the
beginnings of the of the materials
because one thing to be like hey yeah I
you know switch to the tag out here up
in you know Long Beach and so it's made
here technically you know the end hey
look no one's mad at that that's cool
but some people are not well some people
are yes sir right now wrong all right
stand corrected for sure but on the
fiber the cotton is grown in America
that is made in America so these things
are all made in America so like we said
geese crash carts jeans
American denim other things joggers
sweat suits various apparel clothing
items boots so origin boots have like a
more of like a I don't want to say
mystique but you know when you're like
when you kind of see the origin boots
they kind of have a gravitas to them
more so than there's a little something
about them yeah you know how Omar
Bradley said that some people don't have
it yeah well we could say that certain
items in the world also have it I would
say that origin boots have it that is
the perfect way to put it yes yes sir so
get some boots with it yes also
Jaakko fuel okay so i was talking about
staying healthy
staying capable all this stuff like it
hey man supplementation is part of that
that whole deal so important very
important you won't know how important
it is until you joints start giving them
joints start quitting workouts you know
when your elbows are all sore when
you're trying to you know get under the
bench and stuff
yeah trust me it's no good strong
warfare krill oil super krill oil
discipline and discipline go
we got the ready to drink Howie you were
drinking lemon-lime today yeah you know
I
citrus psycho yeah I had the tropic
thunder one earlier
you're too deep huh yes sir
Molk by the way if you're a human and
let's say you you are doing any kind of
activity you need protein
yes might as well get protein that is
clean and that just straight-up tastes
like dessert you know Dave Burke good
deal did ya worried that maybe it was a
weakness yes at night to have a
strawberry milk man that was a very
technical scenario so I could see he
it's a week you know what I evaluated it
slice back into the whole thing where
you used to be like hey Jocko if you're
so into the way your supplements taste
maybe that's a weakness right it's kind
of the same same concept yes I thought I
still think you're wrong
well at the end of the day well if your
results driven oh yeah it it's like
weakness well no I you won't be able to
recognize any weakness in the scenario
so let it go because at the end of the
day you win 100% you're correct I'm not
sure but if we want to go tackle your
intention is something you know I'm
saying yeah I want this day here is good
yeah Dave look this is the thing that we
need to just continue to try and clarify
for everyone if you have a mulk late at
night you're not that hungry but you
want to taste something delicious so you
mix one up it's 11 o'clock at night
let's face it that that's a questionable
activity but at the same time you're
literally providing your your body with
the fuel that it needs to be strong you
know so it's it's there it's a real
thing this is a real soul in a real wind
so I'm going to win yes sir
I agree so yeah get on that get on that
we need to do I need to make a Molk Molk
that
tastes like right just for the mental
discipline just to get a double dose of
discipline you'll get strong and you'll
get mentally tougher because you'll be
drinking something that tastes like
kerosene yeah no don't do that
check so anyway yes malt protein in the
form of a dessert all for it hundred
percent chocolate white tea also you
want something a little bit lighter
organic refreshing if you drink it as
the thing that people really like about
choco whitey is that it allows you to
bet to deadlift eight thousand pounds
yes and that by the way that's
double-blind placebo tested with a
ninety four person control group yeah so
get that and all these supplement items
can be found at the Vitamin Shoppe so
you don't have to order it by mail you
can go and get it from the Vitamin
Shoppe if you need it if you have an
emergency situation yeah you need it
right now Hulk now yeah dig it also we
have a store choco has a stores called
choco store where you can get your
apparel apparel school right there I
mean the word apparel yeah merch that
was the one I think the kids are saying
that nowadays merch we're just cool I
dig it anyway merch if you want to buy a
t-shirt says discipline equals free
don't boom get it there at chocolate or
calm you want to see or you want to get
a shirt that's as good written across
the front good
that's a you got to know what what
that's for you know it's not just saying
good if you want a trucker's half yeah
or a regular hat or a beanie for your
head like fit yeah all that stuff
hoodies lightweight and heavy tank tops
all this stuff yes
Jaakko store commissary came to get this
cool stuff and if you are seen in the
wild by me representing yeah I will give
you a head nod yes the bona fides as it
were oh yeah
what is the bona fides you know you know
what the technical bone if he's wasn't
the military it's like the cheesy thing
where someone says it's a nice night
for a walk and the other person says but
it's cold in Nebraska so it's a little
like I would say to you it's a nice
night for a walk and you would say but
it's cold Nebraska then I go okay cool
hey here's what's going on you know what
I thought it was well I thought it was
nice night for a walk then the other
person says nice night for a walk then
you say wash day tomorrow nothing clean
right then the other person says nothing
clean right what is that from
terminator okay anyway so yes bonus
beauties all day if I see you I'm gonna
give you the same deal I may say nice
and for what my knowledge comes from 20
years of serving the nation to the
military your knowledge comes from
Terminator 2
well that's from anyone but the
estimated two as well that is interest
so I guess basically we both have the
same knowledge yeah same thing
same thing I like to do oh yes and also
subscribe if you haven't already on all
the podcasting places where if you
listen to podcast subscribe you know
that's the thing it's cool yeah speaking
of you know this podcast we also have
other podcasts one of them we're having
some technical difficulties right now we
had a podcast that was previously called
the thread there's already an existing
podcast called the thread which I didn't
know about because I just didn't really
pay attention to it and so we're
changing the name of ours just don't
know what it's gonna be called yet and
we'll put it up there shortly so if
you're missing the thread that's where
it's at it's gone for now we'll be back
we'll put up all the episodes will
change whatever we gotta change so that
it's differentiated from that my my boss
oops yeah the weird thing is there's all
kinds of podcast called the thread or
some variant of that I mean but ours
I think our VTR's was more popular so
they didn't like that and I don't want
people to be confused know it'll
eliminate confusion for sure we also
have the grounded podcast the warrior
kid podcast and speaking for your kids
we've got or your kids soap from Irish
yoga ranch calm is that stuff is killer
soap a live on the Jocko story yet
uh yes you keep giving weird answers
well you know there's the thing is that
mmm no be on the lookout for that top of
that alright so if not go to Irish Oaks
ranch calm and get some soap some killer
soap so that you and your family can
stay clean stay clean also we have a
youtube channel for the video of this
podcast Plus excerpts and which is a big
deal so you know you want to listen to a
cool concept that may have been you know
in one of the episodes that you kind of
remember it'll be as as an excerpts you
can you know you can watch that maybe
share it with somebody if you want but
the last YouTube channel yes we do have
a YouTube channel so as you said it
totally official but the check mark did
they send you something do they contact
you to tell you you're official now um
well we had some help
by some very capable people and yeah
they let us know they yeah we're
official did you feel kind of good about
that were you kind of like you're the
man yes sir I still do I feel like we
have an official YouTube channel that's
good well we do fax better than being
unofficial I'm also psychological
warfare iTunes Google Play mp3 platforms
get yourself some psychological hater to
get you through moments of weakness
flips on canvas Dakota Meyer flipside
canvas calm very cool graphic designs to
hang on your wall hang it in your gym
hang it in your room keep you on the
path some books we got a book called the
code the evaluation the protocols we got
leadership strategy and tactics I
reference that a bunch today we got the
way the warrior kids series there's
three of them where the warrior kid
marks mission of where there's a will we
got Mikey in the Dragons best children's
book ever for the youngins factually
actually we have extreme ownership in
that I gotta mean leadership which I
wrote with my brother Leif Babin and we
have this petite goose Freedom Field
Manual so check those books out we have
national on front my leadership
consultancy and what we do is solve
problems through leadership if you have
issues and your team in your
organization in your company go to
echelon front comm and we will help you
out
we have EF online which is interacting
with all the EF instructors all the
esalaam front instructors including me
Lafe JP Mike Dave Jason Steve all of us
we're on there I should have written
those out make sure I don't miss anybody
but yes that's what we're doing we're
there we are we have shifted to this
online platform for a lot of our
consulting right now due to Kovac 19 it
turns out that this platform is just
awesome we're utilizing it we are
ramping it up so if you want to check
that out if you want to talk to me go to
EF online comm get enrolled in that we
also have the muster coming up it's our
Leadership Conference the first one of
the year was cancelled due to kovat 19
that was an Orlando that ones cancelled
right now we're shifting to Phoenix
September 16th and 17th and then Dallas
December 3rd and 4th go to extreme
ownership comm we moved a bunch of
people from Orlando to Phoenix in Dallas
those are going to sell out even quicker
than normal everything we've ever done
sold out so get there early if you want
to go get registered if you want to get
there and of course we have EF overwatch
executive leadership if you need someone
in an executive position at your team go
to EF overwatch we have military members
that have leadership experience to plug
in senior positions to plug into your
organization if you need frontline
leaders or frontline troops go to EF
Legion dot-com and if you're a vet go to
EF Legion comm and sign yourself up so
we can get you employed out there in the
world at companies where they cherish
the military experience that you have
also America's mighty warriors dot org
mark Lee's mom helping service members
around the world helping their families
and
helping gold star families if you want
to donate or you want to get involved go
to America's mighty warriors dot org and
if you want to hear more of my tedious
explanations or you want to hear more of
echos disjointed prattle then you can
find us both on the interwebs Twitter
Instagram and Facebook echo is that echo
Charles and I am at Jocko willing and
thanks to all the service members out
there who are protecting us from evil
and the same to police and law
enforcement and firefighters and
paramedics and EMTs and dispatchers and
correctional officers and Border Patrol
and Secret Service thank you for
protecting us here at home and on top of
them thanks to the doctors nurses and
medical personnel who are risking their
health to protect ours and to everyone
else out there
remember what General Omar Bradley
commander of the most American troops
ever remember what he taught us
they taught us a lot and let's think
about this he taught us that there are
many solutions to a problem but any good
plan executed boldly is better than
indecision so don't hesitate instead
pick a plan and get after it until next
time this is echo and Jocko out